salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
j'ai fait un peu de rangement ce matin
ça il faut que je m'en débarrasse enfin
ce sera pas perdu pour tout le monde
vous le savez les déchets se trient ils
ont une seconde vie et ce geste est de
plus en plus simple c'est écrit dessus
[Musique]
le problème avec nos déchets et c'est
que parfois nous ne savons pas où les
déposer trois Français sur 4 à vous se
retrouver régulièrement dans cette
situation avec les emballages pour
certains produits on ne se pose pas la
question
ce pot de confiture par exemple à
l'exception du couvercle va atterrir
dans le bac de collecte du verre ce
matériau est entièrement recyclable
autant de fois que l'on veut pour six
Français sur 10 c'est même devenu un
réflexe du coup 85% du verre est
collecté et recyclé aujourd'hui il est
fondu et à nouveau utilisé pour
fabriquer du verre donc que l'on pourra
recycler mais parfois c'est un peu plus
compliqué
ce paquet de céréales par exemple en
carton avec un sachet plastique à
l'intérieur
cette peluche ou encore ce vieux t-shirt
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
ne vous prenez plus la tête triman et
ses consignes de tri vont vous aider
cette signalétique prévue par la loi
anti-gaspillage de 2020 figurera d'ici
la fin 2023 sur la plupart des produits
que nous consommons bien visible triman
et son cartouche infotri indique les
consignes de tri il figurent sur le
produit sur l'emballage sur le mode
d'emploi ou sur le site Web du fabricant
c'est très clair il n'y a qu'à se
laisser guider
[Musique]
une canette de soda l'info figure sur
l'emballage le triman nous indique
qu'elle doit être déposée dans le bac de
tri
la boîte de céréales la foterie précise
exactement ce qu'il faut faire de la
boîte et du sachet le carton au tri et
le sachet en plastique également en
veillant
bien les séparer pour faciliter leur
traitement
la peluche maintenant elle ne doit pas
être déposée avec les emballages
plastiques ni avec les déchets
ordinaires et peut-être donner si elle
est encore en bon état sinon elle peut
être rapportée dans un bac dédié dans
les magasins de jouets qui ont
organisent désormais la collecte ou bien
déposer en déchetterie
quant à ce t-shirt devenu un peu trop
petit vous avez le choix
maigrir mais vous pouvez aussi le donner
à un proche le revendre sur une
plateforme ou bien le déposer dans une
borne de collecte des textiles ou le
donner à une association solidaire mais
ce n'est pas pour la poubelle ordinaire
vous le voyez avec le triment et son
cartouche d'info tri il n'y a plus
d'hésitation et si le triman et
l'infoterie ne figurent plus sur le
produit que vous n'avez plus l'emballage
ou que vous avez un doute et bien vous
trouverez toutes les infos sur le site
que faire de mes déchets
que devient ce paquet de céréales une
fois collecté dans le bac de tri
son carton tout comme les journaux et
les vieux magazines
les boîtes à chaussures
les briques de lait ce carton donc est
recyclé on le transforme en pâte à
papier plus d'un million de tonnes de
papier carton usagés sont collectés en
France chaque année grâce au gestes de
tri avec on fabrique des emballages du
papier cadeau des journaux et des livres
du papier essuie-tout une fibre de
papier peut être réutilisée 5 à 7 fois
chaque année le recyclage des papiers
permet d'économiser 19 milliards de
litres d'eau c'est l'équivalent de 6400
piscines olympiques
pour le sachet plastique c'est un peu
plus compliqué tout dépend de sa
composition les plastiques qui se
recyclent bien comme le polyéthylène de
cette bouteille de lait sont broyées ils
sont transformés en granulés qui
serviront à fabriquer de nouvelles
bouteilles des bacs à fleurs même des
pièces automobiles et s'ils ne peuvent
pas être recyclés les plastiques sont
incinérés dans une usine dédiée cette
opération permet de produire de
l'électricité ou de la chaleur pour les
collectivités crier ses déchets
plastiques limite aussi la pollution et
notamment dans les océans plus de la
moitié des déchets en haute mer sont des
plastiques franchement mieux vaut les
voir atterrir dans le bac de tri
protéger la planète avec le tri yes we
can
comme les boîtes de conserve les
canettes sont constituées d'acier ou
d'aluminium 100% recyclables et à
l'infini
en les triant on limite l'extraction de
minerais cette canette sera fondue ou
récupérer son métal dont on fera une
canette ou une boîte de conserve toute
neuve des clés des montants de fenêtres
des boules de pétanque
680 canettes comme celle-ci recyclée et
vous vous offrez un cadre de vélo
enfin
ce t-shirt
même s'il ne sert plus ici grâce au tri
il sera utile ailleurs plus de la moitié
des textiles collectées entame une
seconde vie vendue ou donner il continue
d'être porté déposez-le comme les
chaussures et le linge de maison dans
une borne dédiée directement auprès
d'une association solidaire ce geste
permet d'éviter les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre lié à la fabrication d'un
produit similaire entre sa conception et
son arrivée dans votre armoire un jean
par exemple parcours en moyenne
65000 km soit une fois et demi le tour
de la terre et puis si votre vêtement
est malheureusement trop abîmé pour être
reporté et bien sa collecte permettra de
valoriser ses fibres déchiqueter et
compacter en rouleau elles peuvent faire
un très bon isolant pour les bâtiments
je commence à avoir la fibre du tri moi
tant mieux
aujourd'hui il existe déjà une quinzaine
de filières de produits pour lesquels un
système de collecte séparé des déchets
est organisé les emballages et les
papiers à déposer dans les bacs de tri
les textiles à apporter en bornes ou à
donner à des associations les appareils
électroménagers les piles les batteries
et les ampoules qui ne doivent en aucun
cas être jetés dans la poubelle
ordinaire il renferme les produits
chimiques polluants et doivent être
rapportés en borne dédiées en magasin ou
à la déchetterie ils sont alors presque
entièrement recyclés les médicaments qui
renferment des principes actifs doivent
être déposés à la pharmacie et les
produits dangereux tels que les huiles
de vidange déposées en déchetterie en
2022 de nouvelles filières sont venus
s'ajouter à cette liste comme les jouets
les produits de bricolage et de sport
qui doivent maintenant être rapportés
dans les magasins spécialisés d'ici 2025
il existera au total 23 filières de
collecte et de tri attends attends
j'arrive pas à tout noter
inutile de prendre
et son cartouche d'info tri vous
permettent en un clin d'oeil de savoir
comment bien les trier le moment venu
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu top
rien à jeter dans ce cas il faut liker
et vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
fait pour rejoindre la communauté des
épicurieuses et des épicurieux à très
bientôt
[Musique]